let's go to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
is the number let's start with our
caller today from the 484 area code
who's calling today from 484 did that
mean that is you who's this hi my name
is Louis I'm from Delaware hey Lois
what's going on
hi there um first of all just wanna say
congratulations on a such a great show I
love listening to your cheer on very
level-headed
I'll take because sometimes I watch Ring
of Fire and it kind of gets me angry in
the morning so I had to stop for a sec
yeah that's because Baron is genuinely
so angry about the injustice --is that
are going on that he gets angry and then
it angers the audience and then
everybody ends up very angry but he does
a good job I think yeah he does and I do
like him and Mike Papantonio knows talks
over the port but I guess gets my main
question since times of the essence
I have a lot of trouble talking with all
my friends they're all positive world
gamers of course I know I know you're
not familiar with what's going on right
there but there's been a lot of backlash
with like virtual signalling and
basically everybody's just like hounding
on cyber punks like portrayal but even
though it's supposed to be dystopia and
now there's what's wager Louis what's
virtual signalling well that's what they
tell me that say that like um saying
that like a lot of these mainstream
outlets are saying are calling it
distasteful like you know you should
have portrayed you know a non-white male
all the time and it's really I mean for
me it's not a problem because I mean I
like I understand them trying to get
outraged clicks but it's making all my
friends basically start saying like this
the left is the left is less fault and
it's hard for me to tell them like this
is neoliberalism basically it's what
hold on hold on edges that we're getting
very much this virtual signaling that
you're referring to which big media
outlets are doing it
um so it's more like the gaming major
now it's like Kotaku um who else is
there there's Rock Rock Paper Shotgun
um let's see polygon like a lot of
people hate them I'll be honest I don't
know anything about this and I'm the
last person who could comment on it okay
but I guess I should get your advice
then like how should I tell them that
this is more of like a corporate sort of
speak rather than like actual like what
really what the left is about even
though like socially yes they you know
are all pro-lgbt you and all that but
like in the essence its profit in the
end that's right I mean this is not
unique to the gaming industry you just
you just got to point out companies
might have an internal culture that is
or seems progressive or left-wing but
that in the end having policies of
treating transgender people correctly
might only seem like it's progressive
right now but actually it's just the way
things are going we treat everybody with
respect and that the idea that that
makes a company left-wing you've got to
look at sort of the how they are
positioned within the corporate space
and ultimately what you will usually
arrive at is the reality that these are
profit oriented companies that's the
number one priority above all else
if being LGBTQ friendly is a path
towards that then they'll do it yes yes
of course so it's very difficult for me
to communicate that done because you
know because they always think that all
these developers have their have a gun
to their heads and that they must do
this and that to pander to to minorities
all the time I'm sitting early it's it's
not affecting the gaming and well it's
it's to a point where it is actually
fact I got it I I really don't know much
else about it so I'm gonna let you go
cuz I've got 52 people holding but I
appreciate the call and I hope to hear
from you very very soon